[Musique]
je dois m'assurer aux manches à balai
non mais tu alors qu'est ce qu'a fait je
les ai vus arriver tout droit il faisait
juste comme ça j'ai dit celui-là il va
attaquer donc j'ai le cul non tenues
[Applaudissements]
c'est une expression à savoir où le
dauphin peut-être est-ce qu un pubis
frisettes un pubis malades niqueurs rôle
ou est un chroniqueur dehors avec toi
d'ailleurs et et jean-michel dehors et
parle un petit peu le mauvais bout de
femme le problème c'est que non pas du
tout beaton beetle new beetle est ce que
vous êtes animateur que vous avez 2 à nu
jetons
[Applaudissements]
il est toujours à ce que l'actrice est
personnes qui étaient beaucoup plus
belle qu'avant tu monte en grade au toi
je te le dis à un moment je pense que
toi et moi ça va se faire faut se
dépêcher quoi je content avec toutes les
aides jeu tout s'entend bien c'est vrai
que tenter peillon c'est pas des axes et
a fait sauter les classes l'écrit et
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas malade et
qu'elle allait prendre fin et classe b c
[Rires]
mimie mathy elle refuse catégoriquement
de payer ces stations stationnement au
parc m c'est trop non on n'y apprend pas
le métro c'est très proches que c'est
pas ça me amel majri bas
[Applaudissements]
ils vont mais parce que j'ai bouffé min
non et je me retrouve des femmes accus
[Rires]
vous nous racontez ce fou à traverser
pas bouffer un peu comme à midi jean
michel maire c'est quoi ta part tu perds
j'arrive à faire un double avec ma [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant tu étais quoi d'ailleurs ce
week-end vous qui a fait quelque chose
de particulier c'est toi que ça fait
[Rires]
drôle aussi